[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lectures we had been
discussing various kinds of displacement
potentials
namely the hair modes displacement
potential the lamy's strain potential
and in the previous lecture the galerkin
vector potential
and in each of them we had seen that in
order to arrive
at a convenient form of the ultimate
governing differential equation
which was either in the form of a
bi-harmonic equation
or a set of bi-harmonic equations
or a
laplace equation or a positive equation
we have to use the
consideration that the body forces were
zero
so suppose we do not want that suppose
we do want to consider
the influence of the body forces and we
do want to arrive
at a representation which
uh depends only on the solution
of poisson equations then what
well as i have written down here the
kind of representation that we do
in order to arrive at such a framework
is the
papovitch noible representation and
among all the displacement potentials
that we have been discussing
this is the most modern one of course
please note that when i say that this is
the most modern one it is still around
85 to 90 years old
and nevertheless it is widely used in a
solution of a different
in the solution of different kinds of
elasticity problems in 3d elasticity
and we will illustrate the use of this
to the solution of the kelvins problem
all right so let me just state the
motivation here clearly
it's twofold here to include body forces
and to
to to set up
the framework
in the form of poisons equation
the form of the
the form of ponzo equations
all right now
uh because uh this is something which
you are actually going to use
uh in in the solution of problems
i believe uh it is it is uh going to be
useful
if i if instead of just the ultimate
representation
of the displacement vector in terms of
the pi papovitch number representation
i actually present to you
the steps that are involved in order to
arrive at that displacement potential so
this this here already is
a major difference from the route that
we have been following in the previous
displacement potentials where i
i just wrote down the forms of the
displacement potentials
without actually going through any
preliminary steps so here we are going
to discuss the preliminary steps
involved in that representation of the
displacement vector in terms of this
papuvitch number representation
there is another motivation here of
course
that if you thought that
in the previous lecture when we when we
wrote down the gallery in representation
if you
thought so let me just refer to that
quickly okay so back in our previous
lecture
on the galerkin gallerian vector
potential
if you thought that this particular form
this here
this was quite complicated uh
and i mean the result of this was
some kind of black magic because it is
not
uh you will probably think if i just
wrote it down
uh wrote down this papa which number
representation you will probably think
that this is some kind of black magic
uh and not just some black magic from
but from an alien world
okay so in order to avoid that kind of
any funny notions
uh let's actually go down to the details
of it
so fair warning first of all that
it will involve a little bit of algebra
uh quite a little bit of algebra
we have to do we have to resort to some
clever tricks
but in the process of doing that i hope
you will be able to appreciate
uh almost a mathematical artistry that
is involved
or that was given by uh both this
gentleman
which enjoyed okay so it's a good lesson
uh
to go through all right so without any
further ado let us get down to business
so the first or first starting point
is to actually go back and refer to what
was written down
in the hemos displacement potential okay
so
so we start out with
uh so
we write that when the
that will be a starting point okay you
will see that it is not just a pure
consequence of the hemols displacement
potential then
ultimately there would not be any
difference between the hemodisplacement
potential and the path
which now be representation but in order
to arrive at this representation we
start with this
okay there will be differences there
will be very important differences
so when the hemos displacement potential
was substituted
in the
normal lamy equations
we had obtained the following
so let us look back to the hemus
displacement potential
way back
so
this is the form that i'm talking about
this one
this last step here okay so
and please note that i am not going to
consider this this rho b equal to zero
okay i am definitely going to include
this because that is the motivation here
to include the influence of the body
forces ultimately
okay so what we have is
lambda plus twice g
let me write that properly lambda plus
twice t
grad del squared pi
plus g
curl of the laplacian
of the vector
omega plus rho b
is equal to 0 this is our starting point
now before proceeding with anything else
what we'll do is we'll will simplify
or rewrite this uh this form in a
certain way
and you will see that i mean it may seem
a little bit arbitrary to you at first
but the motivation is that the the
ultimate forms of the equations that we
want to arrive at
uh they'll be nice and beautiful if we
do these kinds of algebras beforehand
okay so so please bear with uh
i mean bear with this with a little bit
of patience okay
so what we do first of all
is to write this as lambda plus twice g
this thing as uh lambda is e new divided
by 1 plus nu
1 minus twice nu
and this twice g will just keep it as it
is
okay uh this
e by 1 plus nu you note that
this is twice g this e by 1 plus q that
is twice
g
we basically have this so that
what we have here is this thing
as i mentioned uh
initially it may seem all a little bit
arbitrary
but just be a little bit patient here
okay we want to work with this form
so if you substitute this back here what
we are going to obtain
is is twice g
of 1 minus nu
1 minus y 1 minus twice nu
grad del square
pi plus
g curl of the laplacian
of mega vector
plus rho b vector is equal to 0.
and what we want to write this as is
let me go to the next page actually
i just divide throughout by 1 minus or 2
into 1 minus nu
so from the previous page what i have
is g divided by 1 minus twice nu
plus
t divided by
2 into 1 minus nu so this 2 into 1 minus
nu comes from this
numerator here
to write this properly also this
rho b vector divided by 2
into 1 minus nu is equal to 0
all right so here
this thing can be put in a in a in a
nicer form
by noting that this uh here we have a
laplacian operator and here also we have
a laplacian operator
and we can think of uh this
that this laplacian operator can be
taken out of this curl
and here this laplacian operator can be
taken out of this
a gradient of course these things that
i'm saying
rather arbitrarily these can be formally
proven
these these identities that when you
have the
gradient of the laplacian of something
uh you that is
basically equivalent to the laplacian of
the gradient of that very thing
uh similarly the curl of the laplacian
of
something is equal to the laplacian of
the curl of that very thing
all these can be formally proven you can
just do this as little exercises
but we are not going to go into all that
right now
so i'm just going to rewrite this as the
laplacian
of g into 1 minus twice nu
grad of phi plus
g divided by 2 into 1 minus nu
curl of omega
that is equal to minus rho b vector
divided by 2 into 1 minus nu
okay now
for apparently no rhyme or reason
we are going to set this to a variable
this entire thing sitting within this
square bracket
as minus b vector
so first of all you check that this phi
here
is a scalar quantity operated on
by this gradient operator this entire
thing becomes a vector
here the omega vector of course is a
vector
the curl of a vector is another vector
so
overall this first term here is a vector
the second term here is a vector
so overall this entire entity is a
vector and there is nothing wrong with
writing this b vector
the only thing that seems quite off is
that why are we doing this
see the consequence of that okay and
just as a foreshadow of what it will
ultimately turn out to be
this b vector is just one solid part
of the papkovitch noiba representation
okay so as i said earlier that we are
going to build it up
with this starting from the hemos
displacement potential
uh now
so so as a result of this of this
rewriting so when we said this
just let let's write this down because
this is an important thing
uh so we are basically setting b vector
is equal to minus g
divided by 1 minus twice nu grad of pi
plus sorry about that
minus g divided by 2 into 1 minus nu
curve of omega vector
so that's how it would be so what is
basically
what we are basically obtaining is that
laplacian of this and that b vector
that is equal to rho b vector
divided by 2 into 1 minus mu
okay we'll put a box around this
okay this is one part of the pap kovic
representation
but the real some real mathematical
artist is just going to come after this
so first of all you note that
some of you may have a feeling that
okay this does seem to be
a reasonable representation okay if you
just look at our initial motivation
which was to arrive at a framework which
would
involve the force vector
which is the ruby here on the right hand
side
and we also want to arrive at a
framework which is
like a positive equation so this is
definitely like that
it's a positive equation of course it's
a pausing equation over a vector
variable
so it seems our job is kind of done
but you see there is a little bit of a
problem here
the problem is we have just set this
variable this this entire thing is b
now suppose uh
one asks all right you can solve for
this b
vector can you find out the displacement
vector from this
well in order to arrive at the
displacement vector
you have to go back to this
up to the to the uh to noting that
ultimately we are proceeding from this
step and
uh this phi and the omega they are very
much present
within this b vector
so in order to arrive at the
displacement vector u you need
to know what are the values of
phi and this omega vector but
just by knowing the b vector you cannot
say what
what are phi and omega vector
so it is back to square one kind of
thing so what what good does
knowing b to us not much
really okay so
we have to so this is where uh so the
next part
is where uh these difficulties are dealt
with
and it is dealt with uh in such a clever
fashion that you have to sit back
and and think about it a little bit
closely
and try to appreciate the mathematical
artistry that is involved
okay that was uh so all all a great
credit to
the to the work done by papovich and
neubert
okay so how do we go about doing this
so as with any artistry okay
so uh there is a stroke of genius
involved okay
as with any great art there's a stroke
of genius involved
and that genius is to actually
use a certain vector identity here and
again it may seem
rather arbitrary that we were talking
about these displacement potentials
suddenly why are we going to use uh i
mean out of the blue a vector a vector
identity
okay can you see and you see that that
vector identity is not something
uh trivial
so the vector identity that i am going
to talk about let me let me
use this page here uh
it goes something like this
del square
x dot b vector
that is equal to expected
dotted with the laplacian of the b
vector
plus twice of
the divergence of the b vector
as i said uh this seems like
completely out of the blue why are we
even using this
okay uh furthermore you
should ask yourself what is the proof of
this
okay so the first part of that question
what is uh
why are you doing this that will be
clear as we proceed with the
the subsequent steps and as i keep on
saying
you will you'll appreciate the i should
be able to appreciate the
mathematical artistry involved regarding
the proof
i could go into the proof of this in
this page itself
but i will i'll resist the temptation of
doing it and keep it for later
because if i go into that it will break
the kind of the
kind of break the flow of our of our for
development of the popcor which normal
representation
so right now just for now you accept
this
vector identity in good faith and i will
come back to this later
to prove this thing it's not complicated
i mean
all of you can do this using the index
notation but nevertheless
i'll do this okay so we're going to use
this thing
uh so what we do is
we we write this like this it's just
just a
little bit of a transposition so x dot
laplacian of the b vector is equal to
the laplacian of
x dot b vector
minus twice divergence of the b vector
now
we are going to note a few things first
of all if you go back to the previous
page
you see that this del square b
vector which is present here we've
already done this okay we have
we have already obtained this expression
so let's let's use this
okay so since del square b vector is
this
up the x dot
del square b vector
this is equal to x dot
rho b vector
like this okay i think it'll be useful
if i
start uh numbering my equations
okay let's say that
that this is
this is 1 this is
2.
let's say this is three
so what we are basically doing here is
we are using
two please also note that this
x vector that i am writing this is the
simple
x vector uh representative
of uh of the coordinate system
okay so you have to note
that just because i'm writing this as x
vector it does not mean that it is
limited
to the rectangular cartesian coordinate
system
okay this uh this applies equally well
to the cylindrical coordinate system to
the spherical coordinate system
uh and in those cases it will be
corresponding the r theta z uh et cetera
et cetera
okay so this is just a generic
representation
so we have we have some something known
about the left hand side of this
equation number
three up next what about this
this delta dot b vector okay so for that
we quickly referred to what we have in
our equation number one
okay so this equation number one it
gives us an expression for the b
vector so uh if we take
the divergence of this b vector you
please note
that this first term here the divergence
of the gradient of pi that will give me
a laplacian of phi and
this curl of omega this curl of omega if
i take the divergence of that
that is going to be equal to 0 okay
so what we do is
we say that delta dot b vector
is simply
minus g divided by 1 minus 2 nu
laplacian of pi
minus g divided by 1 minus twice nu
laplacian of pi
using one and the fact
that the divergence of
the curl of omega is equal to zero
all right now
uh
if we uh if we if we substitute this
back here in equation three okay so
let's say that
this is our uh this is our equation
number four
and this is equation number five so
substituting 4
and 5 in
3
what we obtain is
x dot rho b vector
this is in the left hand side divided by
2 into 1 minus nu
is equal to laplacian
of x dot b
vector minus
so uh this thing so this is a minus here
so overall this will be plus
this will be twice g laplacian
of pi divided by 1 minus
twice nu
and from here we can easily obtain
x dot rho b 2 into 1
divided by 2 into 1 minus nu and we'll
just take
this uh we'll consider this this
laplacian operator
in a common fashion so that we obtain
this as
x dot d vector
plus twice g
by 1 minus
twice nu
now if you're wondering that uh if
you're still wondering like
why we are doing all this i mean none of
these steps are wrong
okay none of this steps is wrong but why
are we doing all this
what is the motivation uh we are still
dealing with this b vector which we have
artificially said
and we are still dealing with this phi
where are we going with this
well what we do is we set
this part as another
variable and here you note i have set it
as
a scalar variable and that is consistent
with the fact
that this first term here is a dot
product between two vectors which is a
scalar
and this here is a
scalar quantity also so overall this
entire thing sitting within the square
bracket is a scalar entity and that i'm
setting as
beta as minus beta so
uh we write this again properly
that we are setting beta as equal to
minus x dot b x vector dotted with b
vector
minus twice g phi
divided by 1 minus twice nu
so overall what we are getting is
uh is from this equation that
laplacian of beta
is equal to
minus x vector dotted with
rho b vector divided by
2 into 1 minus nu
so what have we actually obtained
just think for a moment okay uh
i'm trying to go through this uh as
slowly as possible so that
you at least take uh take some moments
to
to realize what's going on or at least
to wonder
why it is going on okay
so previously we had boxed one equation
okay we had said that this equation
number two
that is one part of the papkovitch
number representation
and it's kind of good that it it
satisfies
our initial motivation of arriving at a
framework
which involves a positive equation
now look back at getting back to
the equation that we had just that we
have just arrived at
on the right hand side you see
this here is a rho b vector this is
something which will be known to us
in a particular problem the x vector
also will be known to us
because that is dependent just on the
choice of the coordinate system
these are material properties so is it
not true
that this here again is a ponzo equation
where we intend to solve for this beta
okay so previously we had arrived at a
positive equation involving the vector b
now we are arriving at another positive
equation involving this vector
involving the scalar beta so we bought
this box this equation
this will be another part of the paper
normal representation
okay so let me number the equations
so the last equation that i had i used
was this
four and five
let me set this as 6
and this is 7.
so
we note that both
so that that
the previous equation was equation
number two so both
equations 2
and 7 are
poison equations
satisfying
the initial motivation
this kind of makes us happy but
you should not feel too happy right away
because note that uh it's great that we
have found out two positive equations
but just because you can solve the
positive equations based on all the
on the accumulated knowledge behind the
history of these poisson equations
uh or based on the history of these
positive equations uh
what good does it do us are we actually
able to solve our elasticity problem
what is the answer to that well to
answer that you have to
realize that uh you your your job is not
yet done
because we have not yet connected the
the displacement vector the u vector
in terms of this new variables b vector
and beta unless that is done our job is
not done
okay we only we still have in our hand
the u vector represented only and only
in terms
of our starting point which was the
hemos displacement potential
that representation involved the phi and
the capital omega
we have done a lot of algebra we have
done a lot of clever tricks used vector
entities and what not
and arrived at two positive equations uh
involving the
the b vector in the beta we solve that
and we
we find as our answers for we find our
answers for
our beta and the b vector so our next
job
will be to find out expression for the
displacement vector
in terms of that b vector and and beta
and then only we can say that yes we
have a complete
proper representation so uh
so we so we start uh with
with what we know which is the u vector
in terms of the hemus displacement
potential
and try to see if we can rewrite this
thing
in terms of ah so let me
write this again this is the hemhos
displacement potential
this was our starting point here
how is it possible to rewrite this in
terms of the b vector and the beta
vector
all right so if we go back to our
what was i think our equation number one
this is our b vector
so
going back to
equation one we have for our b
vector minus
g
grad phi
divided by 1 minus 2 nu minus
g
curl of the omega divided by
2 into 1 minus nu
now from this equation
uh what we're going to do is
uh we're going to use this curl of omega
vector here from here
this is simply u vector minus
grad of pi so this is the part where we
have to do
a little bit of algebra
and you note that this can be further
simplified a little bit
so we have this uh
minus g grad phi
common between this term and this term
so let's put this as plus
and within bracket we have
minus
1 by 1 minus 2 nu
plus
1 by 2 into 1 minus nu
and then we have this term minus g
u vector divided by 2 into 1 minus nu
all right
now what we are going to do
is see our ultimate motivation here
is to obtain an expression for u vector
involving the b
vector and the beta vector i mean from
this step
you can kind of see uh if you can just
overlook the messiness of this this
expression
we have kind of connected the u vector
with the b vector
but the this grad phi is still lingering
here so we'll have to take care of that
up but we would like to rewrite this
entire thing
in terms of the u vector so what i'll do
is
i'll divide or i will i will multiply
throughout
by 2 into 1 minus nu by g
okay if i do that
uh and i transpose this to the left hand
side so i'm skipping a couple of steps
i hope you'll be able to follow along
because i am dividing by g this term
will
go out but i am multiplying
uh by this 2 into 1 minus nu
so what i will obtain
is this term grad of phi and within
bracket i will have
2 into 1 minus nu
1 minus 2 nu this one will be coming
one and this b
this b vector term will go to the right
hand side
but now this will be uh this will have
an a coefficient in the form
of 2 into 1 minus nu divided by g
all right let me simplify that a little
bit
this is minus 2 plus
twice nu plus 1
minus twice nu divided by
1 minus twice nu
minus twice 1 minus nu by
g vector
so that u vector is this twice mu
cancels with this one
so overall what i have is minus
1 by 1 minus twice nu
grad of phi minus
2 into 1 minus nu by g
b vector all right
i've done a little bit of simplification
but as far as
the job of eliminating this grad phi
that is still left so what do we do well
we want to bring into this bring into
this representation of you
uh the beta okay so
the connection with b is done somehow
you have to bring in the beta
and for that let me look back at what i
have
my beta okay so this is this looks
promising
because here i have an expression
involving the beta
the b vector which uh i don't mind
having in my final expression
and there is a pi here so possibly i can
eliminate my my five from here
okay so i'm going to use this equation
number six
so going back
to equation six
i have
beta is equal to let me just look at
that expression again
minus x dot x vector dot b vector
minus x vector dot d vector
minus twice z pi divided by 1 minus 2 nu
minus twice g phi
divided by 1 minus 2 nu
so see what i need here is basically
this grad phi
term okay so i have to take
a gradient of this gradient of beta is
equal to
minus gradient of x dot b
i don't mind having this kind of a term
uh present here all that i care
is to somehow eliminate this grad of pi
all right now this is looking promising
because
i uh because you can see that
this this grad phi 1 minus 2 nu is very
much present here
so what i can do here is
i can i can
i can write it like minus
grad i divided by
1 minus twice nu
[Music]
that is going to be equal to
one by twice g so again i'm skipping
a step here uh i'm dividing forward by
twice g
and i'm taking this to the side so so
this one and this one will be on the
same side so
gradient of beta plus
gradient of x vector dotted with
b vector
all right so this entire thing
i can substitute by this
so what i'll obtain in the next step
so let me number this equation also
so my last equation number was 7
let's say
this equation is equation eight
and this is equation nine
so substituting equation nine in
equation eight
what we obtain is u vector is equal to
1 by twice g and please note
that here i'll take this gradient
operator
common gradient
of beta
plus x vector dotted with b vector
minus
2 into 1 minus nu
divided by g
vector and in the last neat step
i would like to take this one by twice g
common as i have been doing so as
so so the motivation here is to just
have this one by two g
factor outside uh just like we had in
the case of the lamy strain potential as
well as the gallery convection potential
so what we have overall is
gradient of beta
plus x vector dotted with v vector
minus so we have taken a twice
g out of here so this will become a 4
into 1 minus
nu multiplied with the b vector
this is equation number 10 now you see
that previously we had obtained
this equation number seven
we also obtained this equation number
two
and now we are obtaining this equation
number 10
which is basically our u vector let me
put a box around this entire thing
okay so what we say is that
this is the papkovitch noible
representation
okay so this is
this here is
neighbor representation
where
b vector and beta
are given
by equations
to and
seven okay so this entire statement
this equation ten together with
equations two and seven
they are they constitute the entire
populish number representation equation
two was one part equation seven was an
another part
and finally with the with this
expression of the displacement vector in
terms
of the b vector and the
this b vector and the beta together they
are
uh they constitute the pap covich normal
representation
okay so of course it doesn't look as
clean and neat
as the previous displacement potentials
but
please note very very importantly okay
all our
initial motivations have been satisfied
now why
because both in equation number seven
here
okay in equation number seven we have
the presence of the body force term
this is a poisson equation this sponsor
equation can be solved
we have the means uh the mathematical
means to solve this
poisson equation we also have
this equation number two which again has
this
uh influence of the rho b vector very
much present here this is again a
positive equation
we can very much solve it uh so nowhere
we have neglected the
the body forces and uh
the the final representation may look a
little bit complicated but ultimately it
once you have the solutions for b vector
and the beta
you just have to substitute it here and
your solution
or the for the desired displacement
vector will come out and the moment you
have this thing
uh the displacement vector you can go on
to find out the strains you can go on to
find out the stresses
and your entire solution is done okay
of course when we have to we have to
apply this this method
or for specific problems there will be
inherent challenges to it
but overall uh this which novel
representation has been studied
uh in a proper mathematical way and uh i
mean
there's there's a lot that the number of
good properties associated with the
apopka vishnav representation of course
we are not going to go into all those
details
uh so what remains okay what remains
so one thing which may be bothering you
a little bit
is that we have not yet done
the proof for this thing
we have not yet done the uh so where was
it
we have not yet done the proof for
for this equation number three or
equivalently this one
okay so now what i will uh
what i will do is in a in a separate
lecture i will just
put out the proof of this uh
i mean it's a rather short proof
let me not prolong this particular
lecture anymore
and on that note let me end this
all right thank you very much